it's really nice to be here I'm doing
something a little bit different for
today's talk so nominally I would pick a
sort of a research thread through my lab
and share a little bit about that I'm
doing something a little bit different
today because I'm taking I don't know 20
30 steps back from all the work that
we've been doing in the past seven plus
years
um and turning turning this a little bit
into here is what I've come to see as my
perspective on interaction so it's a
very high level talk we won't really
look at we won't really get a chance to
dive into details but I wanted to share
with you how I think about the pro the
problem formulation itself what problem
are we trying to solve when we talk
about interaction with humans
um and what aspects of these problems
are important what should Solutions look
like and how should that inform sort of
the algorithms that we're building
um and so um kind of taking a step back
I'm immersed in this world of Robotics I
have friends who start robot products
companies I have not as many robots as
you guys have at Stanford but I have one
or two robots in my lab like this arm
here that I like a lot I spend one day a
week with an autonomous driving company
here in in Silicon Valley called waymo
part of the sort of the alphabet
ecosystem today I won't talk about waymo
work but so I wanted to make that very
clear I'm completely just wearing my
Berkeley UC Berkeley hat but what I can
share is
that uh
there's it's a I experienced these
robots day to day right so
um here I am driving taking one of the
first Rider only rides in San Francisco
and it's really cool it's nice to to be
experiencing robots that make decision
after decision in sort of the correct
way
and so it's just it's very it's an
exciting place to be right so I'm
surrounded by robots and everything I do
and you'll see even more of that in some
examples that I'll give how did I get
into robotics where I got into robotics
um I was in in 12th grade about to go to
university
and I came across Steward Russell and
Peter norvick's book and I read it as
much as I could understand right as a
12th grader okay what did I know but I I
got some things out of this and what was
what really resonated with me back then
was this concept of
the way the book was talking about an
intelligent agent like what's an
intelligent agent it's sort of this
agent that figures out what to do you
give it a go and it figures out how to
sequence his decisions to achieve that
goal on its own and that concept right
there was the thing that really drew me
in right it just was so fascinating that
you could do this
so I've learned that you know the way
robots work
um just to kind of establish some common
terminology is they take actions that
change the state of the world they have
sensors that tell them about what is
there in the world and then you give
them some objective
um a reward function cost function goal
whatever you want to call it and they
figure out
how to go about and achieve it a
sequence of actions a policy that
achieves it and we call this many things
I'm going to refer to it as optimal
decision making in this talk optimal
control on the control side
and what's cool about optimal decision
making I think is that it enables robots
to figure out their own strategies for
interacting with the physical world
what do I mean by strategies and that's
going to be a bit we're going to use
this word again and again and again in
the talk what do I mean by strategies
well
um this example when I teach intro to AI
I give this example I think it's
somewhat illustrative so here's a cute
toy example robot in a maze there's a
gem here it gets plus one if it Cashes
in on that if it falls into the fire pit
negative one game ends it can go up down
left right and there's a little bit of
noise so if it tries to go up with 80
chance it ends up actually in the next
cell unless there's a wall in which case
it stays in place but there's a 10
chance of like Wheels sleeping a little
bit and it ends up either on the left or
on the right
um so that's a task and you can solve it
right through optimal decision making in
this case value iteration you know
everything about the world
um and this is what the solution looks
like and so you know some things make a
lot of sense like you if you start here
right you make your way towards the gem
if you start here you go this way around
rather than that way why is that
minus one because the mind because of
the risk of minus one right if you were
to pass by the fire pit that would be
bad
um and it's really cool what happens
here
robot doesn't go up it goes left
where's it go left
so yeah so
vending up here and then it would get
negative one and the game would end and
so what it does is it sort of bangs its
head against the wall or presses against
the wall
um and leans on in so that there and and
it keeps doing that and there's always a
10 chance that it's up to the left of
the right now I bet that we could write
this down
um if we all set and then thought about
it but I looked at this and I was like
huh that's kind of cool and that's sort
of what I mean by a strategy right this
notion of like bang your head against
the wall to
um instead of the obvious thing to do to
avoid falling into this fire pit was
this is this cute little strategy that
optimal decision making just gives you
um and
um uh I have now a a kid uh his name is
Lucas he's one and
um he is coming up with this sort of
strategy as well he's learning to walk
and uh he can't really walk he falls
along and so when he started doing
before actually being able to fully walk
is he sort of discovered that he can
just like lean against the wall and and
make Froggers that way
um so and he's also really cute so and I
think there's something really beautiful
here
um and I as well seen a bit also
practical about really not having to
specify this robot what to do what
actions to take how to behave
um
and uh to just give it an objective or a
reward function and for it to
automatically figure out that in order
to be robust right how do you do that
you press against the wall or something
like that
um and if I change the the problem a
little bit like if I change you know
where this wall is or in this case if I
make it a this corresponds to sort of
the every step costs a little bit if I
make it a little bit more costly per
action you know all of a sudden it's not
really worth it to you kind of you take
the risk because it's not worth it to
wait until the forward action or the
left action resolves into the into that
um left or right motion
so um so you get this notion of
generalization as you tweak the problem
setting there's something else that's
optimal to do and the robot can figure
that out
so
um with this this was an illustrative
example now I'll give let me give you a
research one so it was back in 2010 I
was in grad school at CMU
and Rob plot gave the stock on exactly
the kind of sort of beautiful emerging
strategy that was so fascinating to me
so this is the like dark domain the
robot starts at a start there's a goal
but it's dark it doesn't know exactly
where it is and its sensors work better
in the light than in the dark and so if
it tries to go towards the goal it might
not get to it with enough accuracy
because it isn't exactly know where it
is and uncertainty also accumulates over
time
um and so
what Rob was talking about is this sort
of the underlying Palm DB formulation
and ways to approximate it and and the
solution to that what
um he showed was emerging was this
Behavior where the robot makes its way
into the light in order to sort of
collapse its uncertainty and gather
enough information about its location
just enough so that it can then go and
make it with enough certainty to to the
goal and so again you know you do
optimal decision making you figure out
things like that you should be moving
towards the life so away from your goal
moving towards the light to make sure
you can actually do the task properly
how to move towards the light right how
much and so on is all these details are
are kind of figured out
good so um I'll greatly greatly simplify
here but I think essentially the message
is you take a robot
um you kind of tell it the basics of how
the world Works some version of f equals
ma some version of how the physical
world behaves and all of a sudden it
does magical things
um on its own and this is a video from
Stanford from zico's work of just you
know even super human performance being
attained through optimal decision making
but while these techniques could enable
these robots to kind of go off and do
these magical things I was also
disappointed in grad school that they
were nowhere sort of near enough they're
far from being enough because if you
look at sort of all these pictures of
robots out in the wild doing their thing
there's something missing and of course
the title of my talk will give you a
hint as to what is missing what's
missing is the people right when will a
car go around and there's this
beautifully empty road with no one
inside no the world for an autonomous
car looks more like this or you have to
actually
um interact with all these different
agents make predictions about where
they're going what's going on with them
and make sure you coordinate well with
them
um as opposed to just you know stay on
the road and drive forward
um even
um one of my favorite robots is Wally
and even Wally right
um uh I I would say it's not enough for
robots to work once we killed off the
planet and moved away to space if you
haven't seen Wally please go watch it
it's such a good movie it's not just for
kids it's a great Pixar movie for adults
as well
um so yeah it's not it's not enough to
actually
make robots work once humans have left
the planet
um or to make robots Arc only on Mars
they're around the quadrators kind of
Escape humans either so we use them to
take videos of us as we're skiing
snowboarding running and so on that's
what Adam does at skydio and Mikey is
getting married so Adam lent us one of
these and here I am
um getting married this is my husband
Chris this is my family and we had this
drone that was navigating around
figuring out where the people are taking
pictures of us and so on it was very
noisy though
very noisy so we had to kind of pause
the ceremony for this thing anyway work
in progress
even Wally made itself super useful to
me before we killed off the planet
um so Chris built this and actuated it
um and it rolled in on New Year's Eve
One Night in uh one year and it popped
up this Lego box that opened up and
there was an engagement ring and that
was his proposal so I'd like to say that
the bar is you know that's this very
high now for proposing marriage
um so uh so so you know robots have to
deal with people people are everywhere
and after a couple years in grad school
of working on optimization for robot
manipulation working on these robotics
problems
it really started to bug me that we have
this great optimal decision making tools
for robots that act in isolation
but it seemed like the moment there was
also a person around
even in the same space as the robot
like you know someone in this diagram
sort of walking in wanting a coffee
refill or something like that
it's as if none of that worked anymore
all these tools kind of gone we couldn't
really use any of that machinery and we
were back to things like
um telling the robot what actions to
take or telling the robot what strategy
to use and I have many examples of these
but I think one that kind of connects to
sort of later on in the talk and the
work that doors are not doing was
um in 2010
I was reading yeah I was reading these
papers Rob plaid like black domain
magical things happening with optimal
decision making
uh I was at CMU Google just started
their autonomous driving project
and this article a bunch of my friends
went to work there this article comes
out and it's describing this funny
situation where they were testing the
car and it gets stuck at a four-way stop
because
um uh essentially it pulls over it comes
to a stop there's a person there the
person inches forward as people do the
car predicts the person will go it waits
for them to go by the time it gets it
together to start driving again there's
another person who had inch forward into
the intersection
um the card predicts that it was about
to go and lets the person go and so on
and so forth until the test driver took
over control and sort of this this thing
made it I think it's in the New York
Times I'm not sure
um
so um later I talked to Sebastian thrawn
and he tells me well what did they have
to do they had to sort of program in
this inching forward behavior for the
car as well which was like humans inch
forward into these intersections the car
shouldn't just go there come to complete
stop it should sort of you know kind of
assert its turn also by when it's a
third inch forward into the intersection
um and so there was a human programmer
who had to figure out sort of what
strategy the car should be using where
was all this like crazy Machinery that
gave us beautiful strategies that enable
robots to figure out what to do
um we there was none of that we had to
kind of go back and say like here in
this situation inching forward is the
appropriate thing to do here's how you
inch forward and so on and that's really
frustrating
um
and it's not just because
you have to come up with these these
strategies that maybe that would be fine
maybe that would be a way to build
robots that interact with people
um but unfortunately at some point it
really becomes unscalable for robots to
operate by designers sitting down and
figuring out what their strategies
should be right so a few years later
another article about waymo talks about
how the car gets stuck taking an exit
because it was trying to merge on and
there was heavy traffic and there was
not enough a big enough Gap in traffic
and so the car couldn't actually make
its Lane change and ending up sort of
continuing on to the exit should a
similar thing like the four-way stop at
some high level but you know you that's
an inching forward doesn't solve it you
have to come up with a different
strategy and adapt it now to well
um
how should that work how should it
depend on how much traffic there is when
do I do it when do I not and so on and
so forth and then there's all sorts of
other problems that even look
qualitatively different like um I like
to show this example of imagine that I
am
um I have this robot where unloaded in
dishwasher or something like that and
it's carrying this cup and it's gonna go
and set it on the table but I look at it
and I'm thinking well you're sure
holding this very high up from the
ground so I get a little bit concerned
because if it drops it it will break
that's not kind of the right way to
carry this what I might do I might say
something but I might also just push on
the robot and kind of correct what it's
doing right be like you've got to stay
closer to the table
now
a robot that does optimal decision
making
um what does it do upon having this
external torque applied to it well the
moment I let go it's like well let me go
back to doing the task and what I
thought was the optimal way which is
clear to have a nice clearance from the
table so I keep pushing it keeps going
back and I keep pushing and it keeps
going back and so on and so forth
um so we call this physical interaction
and clearly this too we needed some
strategy for right this is not what the
robot is doing is not the correct thing
and so as designers we can sit down we
can think of well what would be the
appropriate response people have
actually thought about this they talked
about rendering on impedance they talked
about moving in direction of the force
they talked about rejecting the force as
a disturbance they talked about entering
some sort of gravity compensation mode
and letting the person guide you towards
the end and so on and so forth there's
many ways to go about it unclear which
one of these strategies would be sort of
the right way to go for this sort of
problem if any of them
and so that's a long-winded way of
saying
um
is there an alternative what would it
take for robots to actually figure out
the right strategies for interaction
with humans in the same way they're sort
of figuring out the right strategies for
interacting with the physical world
which is something that we've made a lot
of progress in
optimal decision making enables the
robots to figure out what to do with the
physical world
how do we make it
also enable robots to figure out the
right strategies for dealing with people
so I became really fascinated by this
problem
um where you know for instance instead
of having to say hey robot in this
situation you should inch forward I sure
like to say do your job just like you do
your job in isolation but now also do it
in coordination with this human who is
in the intersection
figure it out
and have the robot sort of make sure
that it does the right sort of
negotiation coordination with the person
how um
how might we do that and I spent really
kind of my research career so far
exploring this type of question
exploring how to go from sort of this
robot and isolation model to actually
something where the human is part of
this formulation
where the we kind of the human becomes
part of the state that we're considering
when we do optimal decision making how
do I make the human how do I put the
human human sort of formally in there so
that when I do optimal decision making
the robot can actually figure out how to
do these things in coordination with
people
um and
is that
with the physical world we can get these
things done because we understand
something about
how the physical world works we
understand through the Dynamics of the
physical state we know laws of physics
and so that's sort of either you know we
can write those things down we can
parametrize them or at the very least it
influences the kind of sort of
data-driven models we use
for interaction what do you do like
what's the equivalent of f equals Ma and
in in theory there's Neuroscience right
that sort of tells you that what laws
govern the human brain but we're nowhere
near actually understanding really any
of that right so I kind of like write
down equations like f equals m a for the
brain
um but that's what we're talking about
when it talks about like well now the
human is part of your state so so what
do we do is there an f equals ma for
interaction
um uh and and you kind of how do we get
there
and I think the answer is yes
I think I've come to this conclusion
that roughly if we formulate this
optimal decision-making problem as what
is called a partially observable
general-sum game which is something that
I'll spend the rest of the talk kind of
going through
um it turned out that at least in my
view
um if we acknowledge that the human is
also an agent
that doesn't act arbitrarily but takes
action sort of that have something to do
with some objective that they have
um uh just like the robot takes action
according to its objective
um that we kind of capture this
interplay between human actions and
robot actions
um that that this kind of really gives
us
not not everything about interaction but
that sort of ethicals that may like
structure that we need that we can use
to build upon when we develop
interaction algorithms so you know that
doesn't mean that people are sort of
rational game playing agents that's not
true far from it
um but I think much like f equals MMA
kind of
um captures
some of what's going on but not all
um this too is more like giving us the
underlying structure of how we should
think about interaction and so what I
figured I'd do for the rest of today is
going to go through what all these you
know errors and words actually mean and
what sort of implications they have for
the way we've been thinking about
interaction problems and what sort of
strategies for interactions have emerged
when we've been able to formulate
interaction this way
female Gamers this mathematical
construct I don't want you to think of
something like chess when I say game I
more want you to think about the game of
chicken
you now knows the game of chicken
a few people do roughly you have two
cars going at each other
and they get some payoff depending on
what each other does so if they both
swerve and avoid each other that's okay
that sort of zero zero nothing happened
no one won one but no one lost
if they both go straight and keep going
straight they go they run into each
other and that's really bad for both of
them so that's negative a thousand
negative a thousand and if they um uh
you know one go straight and the
one-on-one Dodges then sort of the one
who go straight wins in this game of
chicken
um
so they each have a utility or payoff
which depends on not just what they do
but what the other player ends up doing
as well you might have heard of the
prisoner's dilemma to a similar concept
there
what did this have to do with humans and
robots coexisting well you know let's go
back to this coordination at the at the
four-way stop so what's going on here
is that I have the human and a robot
they each have a goal they that and it's
a kind of a complex goal and that they
both want to go through first ideally
they both value their own efficiency but
they also all both want to avoid
collisions with each other no one wants
to kind of get into a wreck on the road
um so much like in this kind of chicken
game that we were talking about each of
their utilities depends on what the
other does I can't just look at the
robot and say how good is an action for
the robot it really depends on what the
human also decides to do at the same
time and the combination of the human
action and the robot action end up
dictating sort of the outcome of this
um so that means that what one does ends
up influencing what the other does
and vice versa and I think that's what
this kind of game formulation enables us
to capture
um each agent takes actions in service
of their own objective
um and that results in this influence
back and forth between the human and the
robot now you might wonder in theory
this is true
in practice do we really play chicken
with each other on the road like is that
sort of what what we want uh come on and
it turns out the answer is is in small
ways yes in small ways kind of more
often than you might think you kind of
exercise your game theoretical muscles
as you're driving on the road and here's
an example and this is from dorsa's work
so here I have a car and I have
um a human driven vehicle and if I don't
think about any game aspect what I'll do
is I'll make a prediction about this
Dynamic obstacle as moving forward and
I'll say I need to not collide with this
human good thing I also need to to get
myself into the left lane but I have to
do that without colliding with the
person and so I need to break let the
person go and then try to go on
um after them unless there's another
card coming right in which case I'll
wait for that person to go to and so on
and so forth or so that's one option or
I can keep going so that I don't slow
down and annoy the person behind but
then you know I will mix my my left turn
so I'll have to reroute so those are
sort of the two options right
as humans
I think most of you do not accept that
those are your two options as humans you
invent a third option
which is to nod yourself in there
and expect the person behind to slow
down and create that Gap in traffic that
wasn't there
and that's what I mean by your
exercising your game theoretical muscles
because in order for you to know that
that's a thing that you can do you have
to reason about this person as taking
actions that depend on the actions that
you take as well and that coupling that
Mutual influence between your action and
their action is what a game theoretic
formulation enables us to capture
and so much like in the four-way stop
certain scenario right the human has a
goal the human wants to go first but the
human wants to avoid collisions too
which means their utility depends on
what art the robot does which means that
what the robot does influences what the
human does and once you do this and and
um dorsal is really the first person to
um kind of enable a game theoretic
approximation that captures this Mutual
influence then you end up with the sort
of behavior where the car figures that
yeah I can go in front and expect the
person to slow down a little bit
and not only do you get that sort of
strategy but you also get the
generalization where of course if the
car starts like way in front right it
does something slightly different if the
car starts way in the back of the person
it doesn't try to go for it it doesn't
accelerate and get in front of the
person because that'd be kind of stupid
it's sort of then it breaks and and goes
behind
and now I want to share with you
um I think this is still to this day my
favorite strategy that came out of any
kind of interaction that we've studied
um and uh this was said our assess paper
that I wanted to get drinks after her
riding with dorsa
um and
um I remembered this very vividly
because you know it's like of course
down to the wire and we're still looking
at results and so on and um
dorsa comes to my office
and she says okay I did this thing that
we agreed to and um
you know it makes sense in this
situation in that situation but there's
this really weird thing happening with
the four-way stop scenario that we were
looking at so let me let me share with
you what the weird thing was that was
happening so what we did here is
um
we put the car at a four-way stop with a
human this was in a simulation
um and we gave the we changed the reward
function for the autonomous car its
utility was no longer you know get get
through the intersection as quickly as
possible don't Collide now we have this
very courteous autonomous car that
wanted to
um it was incentivized for
how quickly the human was getting
through the intersection
right so you can imagine that in a world
where autonomous cars are riding empty
and they don't have to be in a hurry and
so on they might actually want to be
nice to the people around they're
supposed to compete with the people
around and so this was a very courteous
autonomous car
and so imagine you're this car right
um what would you do what would you do
if your job was to do something that and
and your you get brownie points really
for not how much Humanity products you
managed to make but this person who
stopped at the same time as you how
quickly they managed to get through the
intersection
thoughts
people sometimes they flash their lights
so motion okay but the car kind of did
the motion okay reverse yeah yeah so so
uh there's there's the there's the kind
of hand gesture stuff uh lights but
lights can be a confusing signal because
you know when whenever people flash
their lights on me I don't know if
they're yelling at me to like stop or
they're telling me to go
um anyway
um
dorsa came to my office and said the car
is backing up
and she had a you she was ambivalent
about this and I was like oh my God that
is so cool I cannot believe that this is
happening
um and and if you if you're probe at it
it's not something that I've seen humans
do but basically in a sort of game
theoretic model right the car models the
person as wanting to go first but also
wanting to avoid collisions if you're
removing yourself as a collision sort of
threat then it makes sense that they
they would go
um so so under this model it makes sense
it's a cute little strategy that the car
came up with that is not what I would
have thought about
um and um
and then we ran a user study and I kid
you not people went faster through the
intersection so this is a user study
with people you know in driving in the
simulator
and what's really cool
is that their papers in human robot
interaction being written about this
so-called back off strategy so people
haven't proposed this for cars just to
be clear but we have found papers where
people propose this sort of thing for
um robots that navigate
around people so imagine that we're
walking there and the robot and I get
add this bottleneck which is the door at
about the same time HRI designers have
proposed that what the robot should do
at that point is to sort of like drive
backwards a little bit and sort of let
the person go through and this is called
the backup strategy and people have you
know evaluated in the context of
navigation and here it was as really
just the natural consequence an emerging
property of
enabling the robot to understand that
there's this Mutual influence between
the robot's actions on the human's
actions once we gave it that we gave it
this objective of being nice to people
all of a sudden this is like something
that actually the robot figured out
for the game enables and that's why I
think it's important to think of
interaction in this sort of game
theoretic lens
um
it gives you this Mutual influence now
although we do some work on solving like
the actual game I think the bigger
lesson for me is is not so much that you
literally formulate at the game as you
literally solve it with approximations
to the game theoretic solution but
rather
um
think about any
kind of
algorithm Dash learning approach that
you're developing for interaction
through the lens of candid support this
type of solution so for instance one
interesting aspect of this of
understanding this game theoretic
influence is kind of going back to this
example
think about an approach for interaction
where you collect a bunch of data and
then you do behavioral cloning you do
mutation learning right so you get your
car to drive in the way that humans
Drive
well humans don't do this so you won't
get this kind of coordination strategy
because you've never seen the human do
that now think about a different
interaction strategy where you learn
um model of human behavior based on
human driving data right and it's just
this Black Box model
that is fit to Prior data
well
and then your robot sort of plans with
that model of the human well to get to
this as the optimal solution you have to
query that model of the human under the
hypothetical like hey what what would
the human do if I start backing up which
is not something that you've seen in the
data right this is presumably will be an
out of distribution query to this model
that you've learned and so I think if
you know ahead of time that you should
expect influence
um and you should expect that whenever
the robot tries to solve its planning
problem or its reinforcement learning
problem it will try to leverage that
human model and query it in ways that
are that would inputs that go outside of
the distribution that you've collected
then you'll be in trouble and you won't
necessarily find the optimal solution so
that's sort of one aspect that I think
it's guided Us in thinking how do we
make models that are can be actually
robust to these queries that the DRL
agent will need to make how do I build
human models that aren't just this black
box but have some robustness guarantees
um or at least empirical robustness
properties
um and so it again it doesn't mean that
you have to think of interaction as this
is the game we shall solve the game but
I think it does mean that you have to
sort of embrace the fact that you should
expect this Mutual influence to happen
and look at how your Solutions might be
able to support or fail to support the
um the this type of
behaviors that look at influence and so
we haven't uh this is sort of something
that we were we've been recently working
on but to give you an example of that
um you know I work a lot with Sergey
Levin he's very into offline
reinforcement learning so one thing that
we're looking at with um with our
joystudent joy Hong is
what kind of data does an offline RL
agent need to see in order to produce
behaviors that look like influencing
behaviors that go outside of what you've
seen in any kind of human human data set
that you've collected is that possible
you know under what properties does that
happen and so for instance this is a
benchmark called overcook that I like a
lot you have two agents and they need to
play this game together where they're
making soup and there's tomatoes and
there's onions and their plates and they
have to deliver it to these delivery
locations and they have to coordinate
with each other on that I cheat with
this Benchmark because it it helps us
actually study the things that I'm
really interested in which is the
coordination between the human and the
robot without actually having to have a
physical human and a physical robot
cooking onion soup together which adds
many layers of complexity on top of the
core of what I'm interested in and so so
cute little Benchmark and this is all I
want to share two videos from Joey's
work from a few weeks ago
um in this one so this is um gonna be
the the offline around agent here
deployed against the real human player
um
and
um what we do is we collect some human
human data of people playing various
variations on this task and then we give
the robot sort of a new objective and
these objectives look like
um all of a sudden in the game you get a
lot more points if the human is the one
doing the delivery uh also you get a lot
more points of the if you make tomato
soups instead of instead of onion soups
and so the robot has to kind of find
ways to sort of steer the person towards
the solutions that end up being higher
points
um and in this little video what happens
is the robot just puts a plate here and
that sort of ends up kind of influencing
the person to pick up the plate and I'll
say this again
the person's sort of focused on putting
ingredients in
um but then and they had grabbed this
onion they were waiting to put in and
then the robot sort of puts a plate
there and all of a sudden what the human
does is like okay I'll get the I'll get
rid of the onion and go and pick up the
plate and and pick up the soup uh that
that's not a behavior that we see in the
human human data but what we see in the
human data sort of pieces of it like you
know if there's a plate on the table and
some particular types of situations then
the human is more likely to pick up the
plate than do the soup if the plate is
conveniently set for them stuff like
that no human has ever like put a plate
there to get the other human to do this
and the data but there's like aspects of
this and we're seeing to sort of how far
we can push offline RL to sort of stitch
together these behaviors here's another
one where it's really useful to make
tomato soup rather than onion soup and
so what the agent does is it's much more
subtle than the previous one but it sort
of when goes in there and kind of blocks
access to the onions and so the person's
like yeah okay I'll focus on the
tomatoes fine and then they do that
anyway so that's the sort of one I
wanted to say about the game aspect
um let me go real real quick to this
partially observable aspect because
that's also important it's not just
about capturing this Mutual influence
it's also about realizing that the
players don't have full information
about each other
and so one aspect here is we talk about
the human objective and the human-taking
actions
um
and you know maybe the human
is going towards the pot of coffee
because in their mind they would like to
get some coffee the robot doesn't
necessarily know this right so it's not
a general sum game where the objectives
are well known to each other
um there might be partial information
same in a driving situation
um we said like okay human has the
subjective going first but wanting to
avoid collisions but I don't really know
how the person kind of thinks about risk
and safety versus wanting to be
efficient and maybe every person does
that trade-off in a different way
um so
um
that should be sure someone tailgating
okay so uh that which happens some
people really have a skewed trade-off of
uh of safety versus efficiency
um so
what's interesting about acknowledging
that you actually don't know something
about the humans internal State their
objectives their preferences their
beliefs and so on
um is that all of a sudden you're gonna
think about what you do observe which is
the human actions as you're sort of
sensor readings the equivalent of these
sensor readings in the in the physical
world these are your sensor readings now
that give you information about what's
going on with this human objective that
you need to know about and so for
instance in this task
um when I push on the arm
what it should do if it's operating in
this partial absorber system is it
should
try to interpret that external torque as
being a sensor reading about what what I
have in mind and
realize that like oh okay this is
actually consistent would you probably
having a preference of me not keeping
these crazy margins distances from the
floor and the table and so on
and adjusting Its Behavior
and response
and here's a generalization of that too
like
speaking of generalization right so I
think that's the right strategy it's not
rendering impedance not go in gravity
compensation mode is actually just you
know adjust the way you're doing the
task
to better reflect what a person probably
had in mind when they decided to start
intervening and physically pushing on
you and this is with a this is with a
cup right where the robot was about to
spill
and the person sort of reorients the
robot instead of spilling again it's
filling again and spilling again the
robot sort of
interprets that external torque as being
evidence that is consistent with the
person preferring to keep the cup level
um let's see we're at 14. so I'm gonna
I'm gonna skip something give me one
second
the way this all started for me was not
in driving was actually in manipulation
um and
uh
it was
about sort of the opposite direction so
much like the robot doesn't
know what the person wants
person also doesn't necessarily know
what the heck the robot wants so that's
how I kind of got hooked into this area
so I'll be remiss to give this talk
without sort of paying some tribute to
that so here's the robot that I was
working on in grad school his name is
Herb and here herb is gonna pick one of
these two bottles
notice that they're fuse bottles because
Vision sucked back then I mean kind of
still does but it's a lot better so back
then there was no deep learning to deal
with and so we had these uh fuse bottles
because they had sift features and sift
features were the features that were
used as input to these objects
these object detectors and and the pose
estimators so when there's two fuse
bottles herb is going to go and grab one
of them
you want to grab the other one
so now
figure out which one herb is grabbing
when we ran the study it was 50 50 it
turns out to be this one over here it
might as well have been the other one
and so what's going on here is that the
robot is behaving in an efficient way I
mean we kind of slowed down this motion
to be able to run this experiment but
sort of it's taking a bath very close to
the straight line and its configuration
space it's very efficient it's the right
thing to do if you're just operating in
isolation
um but it's not quite the right thing to
do in this little game that we were
playing when you're actually
coordinating with a person and so
partial observability is kind of this
two-sided coin where yeah you don't know
about the human and the human actions
end up being sensor readings for you the
robot but it's the other way around as
well the human doesn't know what the
heck is up with this robot and the
robot's actions end up being sensor
readings for the person and if you
acknowledge that then what happens is
you get to figure out what actions to
take where if it's in your best interest
to do so you kind of become informative
with the actions that you're taking to
the person so that they can more quickly
understand what it is that your
objective is and that's what we did with
something called legible motion which
became my thesis work where we are
running this optimization over the
robot's actions and you're seeing that
you start off with a straight line in
configuration space towards the goal on
the right which as we saw was pretty
confusing and as the robot is figuring
out what actions will sort of update the
person's belief the best it's ending up
kind of taking this motion that
exaggerates to the right
and that ends up
um conveying to the person look it's the
subject on the right that I'm grabbing
not the one on the left and again
exaggeration is one of the 12 Disney
principles of Animation people it's not
surprising that you could use these
principles anticipation exaggeration Etc
to make robots more clear more
expressive in their behavior because
people Pixar does that with their
characters all the time but what was
really cool is was just this was a
consequence of optimal decision making
in the system where you acknowledge you
embrace the partial observability that
the human has
and this is the trajectory okay
I'm going to skip the generalization
part
um you can do this with driving style so
you can sort of pick driving styles that
are more informative or less informative
about the robot's objective and its
trade-offs between how efficient you
want to be and how
uh say if you want to be this
does not fall out of optimal decision
making as beautifully and crisply as
I've said so far but I wanted to include
this example too because this is the
closest I've come to actual pixar-like
characters okay so here's what this is
this is a robot Cassie from Couch's lab
and what we did here was
um we
um wanted to get Cassie to move in a way
that is not expressive of its goal but
it's expressive of some emotion to a
human Okay
um so that's the thing that the person
doesn't know it's some sort of you know
quote-unquote emotional state
um and we didn't it didn't just fall out
of optimal decision making we had to do
some work and in particular the work
that we did here was to sort of train a
mapping between
um trajectories and their valence
arousal dominance which is a
three-dimensional space that corresponds
to human emotions
and then what we could do is optimize
trajectories that when projected into
this space are very close to the sort of
the target emotion we were doing so
we're doing optimization but it required
a bunch of work it wasn't just like oh
this strategy emerges right we got a lot
of annotations
um similar here uh you know I say great
weather today now what I can do is I can
use a language model to tap into this to
project into the valence around the
dominant space figure out what emotion
that corresponds to and then optimize
for the robot to show emotion
appropriate for that emotional content
so it didn't get the offer today that
sucks and then the vacuum cleaner is
more sad and close to the ground and
less energy very cute again caveats and
I'd be remiss without showing Monet's
work while she was in my lab of you know
robots expressing incapability like I'm
trying but I can't actually I don't have
the force to open this cabinet okay and
we have to end so what I'll say is
I don't think this is the full solution
to interaction but I think it we benefit
from recognizing that under the hood
we're trying to solve this partially
observable General Assam game the game
aspect gives us this sort of mutual
influence that we should expect between
robot actions and human actions the
partial observability sort of makes us
embrace the fact that we don't know
everything about the human and their
behavior ends up being evident about the
stuff we don't know and vice versa the
human doesn't know everything about the
robot and so
I think they're this there's kind of
this ethicalsma of interaction
um that enables us to account for the
human as part of the state and in turn
enables a robot to use optimal decision
making to actually generate strategies
for coordination and interaction with
people
um uh I started with this book in 12th
grade and I actually got to edit the
robotics chapter in the fourth edition
to actually talk about this game
formulation and how underneath the doll
this is how this is the problem that
robot should be solving not in isolation
and I will admit that this wasn't a talk
about how it was a talk about what what
is the problem formulation what are the
aspects of it that are important that we
should be embracing not any of how we
actually solve these things there's been
amazing students who've worked on
solving these things dorsa I mentioned
Jaime Andrea they've worked on the game
aspect Dylan uh Andrea Smith course
Rohan have worked on the partial
observability aspect
Sandy has worked on the sort of the
expressive aspect if you want to know
how to solve a game like this the
full observability formulation the best
the closest we've gone to is in David's
work with Ellis and with Claire where
where quadraticizing the costs and
linearizing the Dynamics and doing this
iterative lq game formulation
um I'll skip this part
humans aren't optimal game players even
if I could solve the game that's not
very very good
um description of how exactly the human
will act so we work a lot on how do we
get good robust human models by kind of
combining these game ideas with data and
uh we work a lot on we'll get it wrong
okay robots won't have great models of
people ever they might get better and
better but they'll always be error so
how important is that error what
theoretical consequence does it have on
the inference that the robot does how do
I robustify that inference how do I do
how do I detect that I have the wrong
model so those are all aspects of what
it means to do work kind of but it's all
grounded in this perspective of
interaction as this partially observable
Dynamic journalism game which has really
been my ethical as a main guiding lens
for interaction so with that thank you
and thanks to all the members of my lab
who've actually done this work past and
present thanks for listening thank you